BUT WE ALSO SEE THIS FAR LEFT
HYSTERIA IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
CORONAVIRUS.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS LIKE SCHUMER HATES
DONALD TRUMP SO MUCH, DOESN’T
WANT HIM UPDATING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHILE PEOPLE ARE WORRIED,
THEY WANT UPDATES, THEY DESERVE
UPDATES, SOME ARE SUFFERING.
WE WANT TO END THE INVISIBLE
ENEMY AND DESTROY IT.
WE ARE WELL ON OUR WAY AND WILL
HAVE AN UPDATE TONIGHT.
SPEAKER PELOSI LITERALLY CALLING
THE CORONAVIRUS THE TRUMP VIRUS
AND USING TERMS LIKE
STORMTROOPERS.
HOW SICK IS THIS RADICAL GROUP
OF SOCIALISTS AND HOW REPULSIVE?
ALSO TODAY, FAKE NEWS CNN AS
THEY HAVE DONE IN THE PAST WHERE
THEY DON’T TAKE ANY OF THE
PRESIDENT’S COMMENTS ARE UPDATES
ON COVID-19, LET’S TRY AND STUMP
TRUMP PORTION STARTS.
HOPING FOR A GOTCHA MOMENT ONLY,
NOT SHOWING VIEWERS ALL OF THE
IMPORTANT FACTS, STATISTICS AND
UPDATES THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
AMERICAN FAMILIES, AND BY THE
WAY BY IT A TELEPROMPTER, VERY
BIZARRE TODAY, DOESN’T TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS DURING THAT SHORT
FRANKLY DUMB PRESSER.
HIS WORDS ARE MEANINGLESS
BECAUSE BY IT, SCHUMER, PELOSI
NOW HAVE 125 YEARS COMBINED
FAILURE AND BROKEN PROMISES IN
THE SWAMP.
WHO KNOWS IF BIDEN IS EVEN ABLE
TO REALLY TRULY ANSWER TOUGH
UNSCRIPTED QUESTIONS.
THAT HAS YET TO BE DETERMINED.
IS NOW CLEAR FAKE NEWS CNN IS
NOTHING BUT A RANGE OF FAILED
VINDICTIVE TRUMP CULT.
THEY HATE TRUMP SO MUCH THEY
DON’T EVEN WANT THEIR OWN
VIEWERS TO DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES
AND HEAR CRITICAL LIFE-SAVING
INFORMATION, PROGRESS
SURROUNDING COVID-19, NEW
INFORMATION ON THERAPEUTICS,
ADVANCEMENT WITH VACCINES,
PRETTY PATHETIC AND ALSO
PREDICTABLE AND HERE ARE THE
STATISTICS THAT FAKE NEWS CNN
VIEWERS DIDN’T GET TODAY.
FATALITIES IN THE U.S. HAVE
FALLEN SINCE APRIL, OUR COVID-19
FATALITY RATE IS NOW LOWER THAN
THE ENTIRE E.U. AND MOST OTHER
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD.
CHILDREN HAVE A NEAR ZERO
FATALITY RISK, HOSPITAL STAYS
HAVE NOW BEEN CUT IN HALF,
STOCKPILES, PPE, MEDICAL
TREATMENTS, MEDICINES ARE
SURGING.
TESTING CAPACITY IS NOW
QUADRUPLED IN JUST THE LAST 60
DAYS ALONE.
THE UNITED STATES HAS CONDUCTED
NOW ALMOST 50 MILLION TESTS,
MORE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY ON
EARTH.
INDIA COMES IN SECOND WITH
12 MILLION TESTS AND WE HAVE NOW
CONDUCTED 50% MORE TEST PER
CAPITA THAN EUROPE, THREE TIMES
MORE THAN THE REST OF THE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE COMBINED.
NOW, THERE HAVE BEEN ZERO
UNFULFILLED EQUIPMENT AND SUPPLY
REQUESTS FROM STATE GOVERNORS
EVEN IN THE SUN BELT, THESE
SO-CALLED HOT ZONES ARE
HOT SPOTS AND TO DATE, ALL
STATES AND THE ADMINISTRATION
HAVE SUFFICIENT HOSPITAL
CAPACITY.
AND BY THE WAY, NOW NEARLY 7,000
NATIONAL GUARD, MILITARY MEDICAL
PERSONNEL IN TEXAS, CALIFORNIA,
FLORIDA, AND ARIZONA.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO SENT SENIOR
OFFICIALS TO NINE STATES TO
COORDINATE THE EFFORTS ON THE
GROUND.
YOU WOULDN’T KNOW IT IF YOU WERE
WATCHING FAKE NEWS, BUT LAST BUT
NOT LEAST, TO GO VACCINES,
ACTUALLY OVER 100, BUT TWO NOW,
MADURA AND ASTRAZENECA AND THAT
OXFORD STUDY ENTERING THE FINAL
PHASE OF TESTING.
AND THEY START THAT IN FOUR DAYS
AND THAT’S FOR VACCINES AND THEY
HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS.
USED TO TAKE YEARS TO BREAK DOWN
THE SEQUENCE OF A VIRUS.
WE NOW DID IT IN SIX WEEKS, A
RECORD.
WILL HAVE A RECORD TIME FOR A
VACCINE AS WELL.
THERAPEUTICS DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVING, THANK GOD.
AT FIRST VACCINE THAT CLEARS THE
FINAL TESTING THRESHOLD WILL BE
MADE AVAILABLE IMMEDIATELY,
PRESIDENT OUTLINED A FULL
LOGISTICAL SUPPORT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE U.S.
MILITARY TO GET IT OUT TO WHERE
IT NEEDS TO BE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
WHY WOULDN’T FAKE NEWS CNN WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THIS IMPRESSIVE
PROGRESS?
THAT’S RIGHT, BECAUSE IT EXPOSES
THEM.
AND IT MIGHT ACTUALLY SHOW
DONALD TRUMP IS DOING HIS JOB.
EVERYTHING THEY’VE BEEN TELLING
THEIR VIEWERS, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, HOAXES, LIES, NEVER
ENDING.
BY THE WAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
NEVER STOPPED WORKING.
THE PANDEMIC IS NOT SPIRALING
OUT OF CONTROL AS THEY PROJECTED
NIGHTLY.
IS THE WORST PANDEMIC SINCE 1918
LOSING ONE LIFE IS WAY TOO MANY.
THE SITUATION IS GETTING BETTER,
NOT WORSE AND BY THE WAY, AND OF
THESE PEOPLE ON TVs AND NO
DEMOCRATS SUPPORTED THE TRAVEL
BAN TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED CASE IN CORONAVIRUS
AND THE SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL BANDS
ON THE FIRST QUARANTINE IN OVER
15 YEARS.
THAT ALONE BECOME A HUGE
DECISION TO SAVE LIVES.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
FULFILLED EVERY REQUEST FROM
EVERY STATE GOVERNOR.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FATALITIES NATIONWIDE HAVE
FALLEN.
75% SINCE MID-APRIL.
THAT’S A GREAT NUMBER HAS CASES
AND FATALITIES RISE IN CERTAIN
HARD-HIT STATES WHICH YOU ARE
LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE IMPLORING YOUNG AMERICANS
TO AVOID PACKED BARS AND OTHER
CROWDED INDOOR GATHERINGS, BE
SAFE AND BE SMART.
SURGING TESTING CAPACITY TO
IDENTIFY AND ISOLATE CASES.
THIS INCLUDES A NEWLY APPROVED
TESTING PLATFORM TO NURSING
HOMES ACROSS THE SOUTH, BEING
VERY VIGILANT WITH RESPECT TO
NURSING HOMES, ULTIMATELY OUR
GOAL IS NOT MERELY TO MANAGE THE
PANDEMIC, BUT THE END IT.
WE WANT TO GET RID OF IT AS SOON
AS WE CAN.
THAT IS BY GETTING A VACCINE
REMAINS A TOP PRIORITY.
>> Sean: SHOWING VIEWERS THESE
IMPORTANT FACTS ABOUT AMERICA’S
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST COVID-19, THE MOB,
THE MEDIA, THE FELLOW DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS WOULD RATHER RIBS AS
OF LATE COMPULSIVELY TRASH THE
PRESIDENT.
NANCY PELOSI NOW ACTUALLY GOING
THIS FAR SAYING IT’S NOT THE
WUHAN VIRUS HAS FAKE NEWS CNN
ONCE CALLED IT, NOT THE CHINESE
VIRUS, NOT ALLOWED TO SAY THAT,
SHE IS CALLING AT THE TRUMP
VIRUS.
OF COURSE.
THE DOG BITES, THE BEE STINGS,
IF YOU’RE FEELING SAD, BLAME
DONALD TRUMP.
YOU CURE CANCER, THEY BLAME
>> RECOGNIZE THIS MISTAKES HE
HAS MADE NOW EMBRACING MASK
WEARING AND THE RECOGNITION THAT
IT’S NOT A HOAX, IT IS A
PANDEMIC THAT HAS GOTTEN WORSE
BEFORE IT WILL GET BETTER
BECAUSE OF HIS INACTION AND
CLEARLY, IT IS THE TRUMP VIRUS.
>> Sean: SO WHERE WAS NANCY
AND CHUCK AND ALL THE DEMOCRATS
ON JANUARY 31ST AFTER THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED CASE FROM
JANUARY 21ST 10 DAYS AFTER WHAT
HE WAS PUTTING IN PLACE THAT
HYSTERICAL XENOPHOBIC
FEARMONGERING TRAVEL BAN AND THE
SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL BAN AND THE
QUARANTINE, THAT’S RIGHT, THEY
WERE IMPEACHING THEM WHILE
IGNORING QUID PRO QUO JOE IN
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER.
IN ADDITION TO USING IT AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON, DEMOCRATS ARE
ALSO ENGAGING IN THEIR OTHER
FAVORITE PAST TIME CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
AS OF LATE, FAVORITE HOAX
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL REFUSE TO
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE
WHITE HOUSE.
HE LOSES IN NOVEMBER EMMA THEY
BELIEVE THIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FIRST THING WE SHOULD BE
DOING NOW IS UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS ALREADY DOING
TO THE U.S. POSTAL SERVICE.
HE HAS SENT HIS HENCHMEN OVER TO
RUN IT AND ALREADY GETTING
COMPLAINTS FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
SAYING THAT THEY BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS MANAGING THE DELIVERY SYSTEM,
SLOWING IT DOWN, INTERFERING
WITH PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO GET
THEIR MAIL.
WE MET WE ARE LOOKING AT A TRIAL
RUN FOR A GENUINE ATTEMPT
THROUGH INTIMIDATION AND
POTENTIALLY THROUGH FORCE TO TRY
TO STEAL THIS ELECTION.
>> I THINK IT IS A FAIR POINT TO
RAISE AS TO WHETHER OR NOT IF HE
LOSES, HE IS GOING TO GO QUIETLY